The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: One correction
from last time.
Sorry to say, I forgot
a very important factor
when I was telling you
what an average value is.
If you don't put in
that factor, it's
only half off on
the exam problem
that will be given on this.
So I would have gotten half off
for missing out on this factor,
too.
So remember you have
to divide by n here,
certainly when you're
integrating over 0 to n,
the Riemann sum is
the numerator here.
And if I divide
by n on that side,
I've got to divide by
n on the other side.
This was meant to illustrate
this idea that we're
dividing by the total here.
And we are going to be talking
about average value in more
detail.
Not today, though.
So this has to do
with average value.
And we'll discuss it
in considerable detail
in a couple of days, I guess.
Now, today I want to continue.
I didn't have time to
finish my discussion
of the Fundamental
Theorem of Calculus 2.
And anyway it's very
important to write it
down on the board
twice, because you
want to see it at least twice.
And many more times as well.
So let's just remind
you, the second version
of the Fundamental Theorem of
Calculus says the following.
It says that the
derivative of an integral
gives you the
function back again.
So here's the theorem.
And the way I'd like
to use it today,
I started this
discussion last time.
But we didn't get into it.
And this is something that's
on your problem set along
with several other examples.
Is that we can use this to
solve differential equations.
And in particular,
for example, we
can solve the equation y'
= 1 / x with this formula.
Namely, using an integral.
L(x) is the integral
from 1 to x of dt / t.
The function f(t) is just 1 / t.
Now, that formula can be
taken to be the starting place
for the derivation of all the
properties of the logarithm
function.
So what we're going
to do right now
is we're going to take
this to be the definition
of the logarithm.
And if we do that, then I
claim that we can read off
the properties of the
logarithm just about as
easily as we could before.
And so I'll illustrate that now.
And there are a
few other examples
of this where somewhat more
unfamiliar functions come up.
This one is one that in theory
we know something about.
The first property
of this function
is the one that's already given.
Namely, its derivative is 1/x.
And we get a lot of information
just out of the fact
that its derivative is 1/x.
The other thing that
we need in order
to nail down the function,
besides its derivative,
is one value of the function.
Because it's really not
specified by this equation,
only specified up to a
constant by this equation.
But we nail down that
constant when we evaluate it
at this one place, L(1).
And there we're getting
the integral from 1 to 1
of dt / t, which is 0.
And that's the case with all
these definite integrals.
If you evaluate them at
their starting places,
the value will be 0.
And together these
two properties
specify this function
L(x) uniquely.
Now, the next step
is to try to think
about what its properties are.
And the first approach
to that, and this
is the approach
that we always take,
is to maybe graph the function,
to get a feeling for it.
And so I'm going to take
the second derivative.
Now, notice that when
you have a function which
is given as an integral,
its first derivative
is really easy to compute.
And then its second
derivative, well, you
have to differentiate
whatever you get.
So it may or may not be easy.
But anyway, it's a
lot harder in the case
when I start with a function to
get to the second derivative.
Here it's relatively easy.
And these are the properties
that I'm going to use.
I won't really use very much
more about it than that.
And qualitatively,
the conclusions
that we can draw from
this are, first of all,
from this, for example
we see that this thing is
concave down every place.
And then to get
started with the graph,
since I see I have a value
here, which is L(1) = 0,
I'm going to throw in
the value of the slope.
So L'(1), which I
know is 1 over 1,
that's reading off from this
equation here, so that's 1.
And now I'm ready to sketch
at least a part of the curve.
So here's a sketch of the graph.
Here's the point (1, 0),
that is, x = 1, y = 0.
And the tangent line,
I know, has slope 1.
And the curve is concave down.
So it's going to look
something like this.
Incidentally, it's
also increasing.
And that's an
important property,
it's strictly increasing.
That's because
L'(x) is positive.
And so, we can get from this the
following important definition.
Which, again, is working
backwards from this definition.
We can get to where
we started with a log
in our previous discussion.
Namely, if I take the
level here, which is y = 1,
then that crosses
the axis someplace.
And this point is what
we're going to define as e.
So the definition
of e is that it's
the value such that L(e) = 1.
And again, the fact that
there's exactly one such place
just comes from the fact
that this L' is positive,
so that L is increasing.
Now, there's just one
other feature of this graph
that I'm going to
emphasize to you.
There's one other thing
which I'm not going to check,
which you would
ordinarily do with graphs.
Once it's increasing there
are no critical points,
so the only other interesting
thing is the ends.
And it turns out that the
limit as you go down to 0
is minus infinity.
As you go over to the right
here it's plus infinity.
It does get arbitrarily
high; it doesn't level off.
But I'm not going to
discuss that here.
Instead, I'm going
to just remark
on one qualitative feature of
the graph, which is this remark
that the part which is to
the left of 1 is below 0.
So I just want to remark, why
is L(x) negative for x < 1.
Maybe I don't have room for
that, so I'll just put in here:
x < 1.
I want to give you two reasons.
Again, we're only working from
very first principles here.
Just that-- the property
that L' = 1/x, and L(1) = 0.
So our first reason is
that, well, I just said it.
L(1) = 0.
And L is increasing.
And if you read that backwards,
if it gets up to 0 here,
it must have been
negative before 0.
So this is one way of seeing
that L(x) is negative.
There's a second way of seeing
it, which is equally important.
And it has to do with just
manipulation of integrals.
Here I'm going to start out
with L(x), and its definition.
Which is the integral
from 1 to x, dt / t.
And now I'm going to reverse
the order of integration.
This is the same, by our
definition of our properties
of integrals, as the
integral from x to 1
with a minus sign dt / t.
Now, I can tell that this
quantity is negative.
And the reason
that I can tell is
that this chunk of it
here, this piece of it,
is a positive number.
This part is positive.
And this part is
positive because x < 1.
So the lower limit is
less than the upper limit,
and so this is interpreted
- the thing in the green box
is interpreted - as an area.
It's an area.
And so negative a positive
quantity is negative,
minus a positive
quantity's negative.
So both of these work perfectly
well as interpretations.
And it's just to
illustrate what we can do.
Now, there's one
more manipulation
of integrals that gives us the
fanciest property of the log.
And that's the last one
that I'm going to do.
And you have a similar
thing on your homework.
So I'm going to
prove that-- This
is, as I say, the fanciest
property of the log.
On your homework, by the way,
you're going to check that
L(1/x) = -L(x).
But we'll do this one.
The idea is just to plug in the
formula and see what it gives.
On the left-hand side,
I have 1 to ab, dt / t.
That's L(ab).
And then that's certainly
equal to the left-hand side.
And then I'm going to now
split this into two pieces.
Again, this is a
property of integrals.
That if you have an integral
from one place to another,
you can break it up into pieces.
So I'm going to start
at 1 but then go to a.
And then I'm going to
continue from a to ab.
So this is the
question that we have.
We haven't proved this.
Well, this one is actually true.
If we want this to
be true, we know
by definition L(ab) is this.
We know, we can see
it, that L(a) is this.
So the question that
this boils down to
is, we want to know that
these two things are equal.
We want to know that L(b) is
that other integral there.
So let's check it.
I'm going to rewrite
the integral.
It's the integral from--
sorry, from lower limit a
to upper limit ab of dt / t.
And now, again, to
illustrate properties
of integrals, the
key property here
that we're going to have to
use is change of variables.
This is a kind of a scaled
integral where everything
is multiplied by a
factor of a from what
we want to get to
this L(b) quantity.
And so this suggests that
we write down t = au.
That's going to be our trick.
And if I use that new variable
u, then the change in t,
dt, is a du.
And as a result, I can write
this as equal to an integral
from, let's see, dt = a du.
And t = au.
So I've now substituted
in for the integrand.
But on top of this,
with definite integrals,
we also have to
check the limits.
And the limits work
out as follows.
When t = a, that's
the lower limit.
Let's just take a look. t = au.
So that means that
u is equal to, what?
It's 1.
Because a * 1 = a.
So if t = a, this
is if and only if.
So this lower limit, which
really in disguise was where
t = a, becomes where u = 1.
And similarly,
when t = ab, u = b.
So the upper limit here is b.
And now, if you
notice, we're just
going to cancel these
two factors here.
And now we recognize that
this is just the same
as the definition of L(b).
Because L(x) is over
here in the box.
And the fact that I use the
letter t there is irrelevant;
it works equally well
with the letter u.
So this is just L(b).
Which is what we wanted to show.
So that's an
example, and you have
one in your homework,
which is a little similar.
Now, the last example, that I'm
going to discuss of this type,
I already mentioned last time.
Which is the function F(x),
which is the integral from 0
to x of e^(-t^2) dt.
This one is even more exotic
because unlike the logarithm
it's a new function.
It really is not any
function that you
can express in terms of the
functions that we know already.
And the approach, always,
to these new functions
is to think of what
their properties are.
And the way we think
of functions in order
to understand them is
to maybe sketch them.
And so I'm going to do exactly
the same thing I did over here.
So, what is it that I
can get out of this?
Well, immediately I can figure
out what the derivative is.
I read it off from the
fundamental theorem.
It's this.
I also can figure out the
value at the starting place.
In this case, the
starting place is 0.
And the value is 0.
And I should check the second
derivative, which is also not
so difficult to compute.
The second derivative
is -2x e^(-x^2).
And so now I can see that
this function is increasing,
because this
derivative is positive,
it's always increasing.
And it's going to be concave
down when x is positive
and concave up
when x is negative.
Because there's a minus sign
here, so the sign is negative.
This is less than 0 when x is
positive and greater than 0
when x is negative.
And maybe to get started
I'll remind you F(0) is 0.
It's also true that F'(0)-- that
just comes right out of this,
F'(0) = e^(-0^2), which is 1.
That means the tangent
line again has slope 1.
We do this a lot with functions.
We normalize them so that the
slopes of their tangent lines
are 1 at convenient spots.
So here's the tangent
line of slope 1.
We know this thing is
concave down to the right
and concave up to the left.
And so it's going to
look something like this.
With an inflection point.
Right?
Now, I want to say one
more-- make one more remark
about this function,
or maybe two more
remarks about this
function, before we go on.
Really, you want to know this
graph as well as possible.
And so there are just
a couple more features.
And one is enormously
helpful because it
cuts in half all of
the work that you have.
and that is the
property that turns out
that this function is odd.
Namely, - F(-x) = -F(x).
That's what's known
as an odd function.
Now, the reason why it's odd
is that it's the antiderivative
of something that's even.
This function in here is even.
And we nailed it down
so that it was 0 at 0.
Another way of interpreting
that, and let me show it to you
underneath, is the following.
When we look at its derivative,
its derivative, course,
is the function e^x.
Sorry, e^(-x^2).
So that's this shape here.
And you can see the slope is
0, but-- fairly close to 0,
but positive along here.
It's getting, this is
its steepest point.
This is the highest point here.
And then it's
leveling off again.
The slope is going
down, always positive.
This is the graph
of F' = e^(-x^2).
Now, the interpretation of
the function that's up above
is that the value here
is the area from 0 to x.
So this is area F(x).
Maybe I'll color it in,
decorate it a little bit.
So this area here is F(x).
Now, I want to show
you this odd property,
by using this symmetry.
The graph here is even,
so in other words,
what's back here is exactly
the same as what's forward.
But now there's a reversal.
Because we're keeping
track of the area
starting from 0 going forward.
That's positive.
If we go backwards,
it's counted negatively.
So if we went
backwards to -x, we'd
get exactly the same as
that green patch over there.
We'd get a red patch over here.
But it would be
counted negatively.
And that's the
property that it's odd.
You can also check this
by properties of integrals
directly.
That would be just
like this process here.
So it's completely analogous
to checking this formula
over there.
So that's one of the comments
I wanted to make about this.
And why does this
save us a lot of time,
if we know this is odd?
Well, we know that the
shape of this branch
is exactly the reverse,
or the reflection,
if you like, of the
shape of this one.
What we want to do is
flip it under the axis
and then reflect
it over that way.
And that's the symmetry
property of the graph of F(x).
Now, the last property
that I want to mention
is what's happening
with the ends.
And at the end
there's an asymptote,
there's a limit here.
So this is an asymptote.
And the same thing
down here, which
will be exactly because
of the odd feature,
this'll be exactly negative.
The opposite value over here.
And you might ask yourself,
what level is this, exactly.
Now, that level turns out to
be a very important quantity.
It's interpreted
down here as the area
under this whole
infinite stretch.
It's all the way
out to infinity.
So, let's see.
What do you think it is?
You're all clueless.
Well, maybe not all of you,
you're just afraid to say.
So it's obvious.
It's the square root of pi/2.
That was right on the tip
of your tongue, wasn't it?
STUDENT: Ah, yes.
PROFESSOR: Right, so this
is actually very un-obvious,
but it's a very
important quantity.
And it's an amazing
fact that this thing
approaches this number.
And it's something that people
worried about for many years
before actually nailing down.
And so what I just
claimed here is
that the limit as x
approaches infinity of F(x)
is equal to the square
root of pi over 2.
And similarly, if you
do it to minus infinity,
you'll get minus square
root of pi over 2.
And for this reason, people
introduced a new function
because they like the number 1.
This function is erf,
short for error function.
And it's 2 over the square root
of pi times the integral from 0
to x, e^(-t^2) dt.
In other words, it's
just our original,
our previous function
multiplied by 2
over the square root of pi.
And that's the function which
gets tabulated quite a lot.
You'll see it on the
internet everywhere,
and it's a very
important function.
There are other
normalizations that are used,
and the discussions of
the other normalizations
are in your problems.
This is one of them, and another
one is in your exercises.
The standard normal
distribution.
There are tons of
functions like this,
which are new functions
that we can get at once we
have the tool of integrals.
And I'll write down just
one or two more, just so
that you'll see the variety.
Here's one which is
called a Fresnel integral.
On your problem set
next week, we'll
do the other Fresnel integral,
we'll look at this one.
These functions cannot be
expressed in elementary terms.
The one on your homework
for this week was this one.
This one comes up
in Fourier analysis.
And I'm going to just tell you
maybe one more such function.
There's a function
which is called
Li(x), logarithmic integral
of x, which is this guy.
The reciprocal of the
logarithm, the natural log.
And the significance
of this one is
that Li(x) is approximately
equal to the number of primes
less than x.
And, in fact, if you can make
this as precise as possible,
you'll be famous for millennia,
because this is known
as the Riemann hypothesis.
Exactly how closely this
approximation occurs.
But it's a hard
problem, and already
a century ago the
prime number theorem,
which established this
connection was extremely
important to progress in math.
Yeah, question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Is this stuff
you're supposed to understand.
That's a good question.
I love that question.
The answer is, this is, so we
launched off into something
here.
And let me just
explain it to you.
I'm going to be talking
a fair amount more
about this particular function,
because it's associated
to the normal distribution.
And I'm going to let you
get familiar with it.
What I'm doing here
is purely cultural.
Well, after this panel, what
I'm doing is purely cultural.
Just saying there's
a lot of other beasts
out there in the world.
And one of them
is called C of x--
So we'll have a just a very
passing familiarity with one
or two of these functions.
But there are literally
dozens and dozens of them.
The only thing that you'll
need to do with such functions
is things like understanding
the derivative,
the second derivative,
and tracking
what the function does.
Sketching the same way you
did with any other tool.
So we're going to do this type
of thing with these functions.
And I'll have to
lead you through.
If I wanted to ask you
a question about one
of these functions,
I have to tell you
exactly what I'm aiming for.
Yeah, another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I did.
I called these guys
Fresnel integrals.
The guy's name is Fresnel.
It's just named after a person.
But, and this one, Li
is logarithmic integral,
it's not named after a person.
Logarithm is not
somebody's name.
So look, in fact this
will be mentioned also
on a problem set,
but I don't expect
you to remember these names.
In particular,
that you definitely
don't want to try to remember.
Yes, another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question is,
will we prove this limit.
And the answer is
yes, if we have time.
It'll be in about a week or so.
We're not going to do it now.
It takes us quite a
bit of work to do it.
OK.
I'm going to change gears
now, I'm going to shift gears.
And we're going to go back
to a more standard thing
which has to do with just
setting up integrals.
And this has to do with
understanding where integrals
play a role, and they play
a role in cumulative sums,
in evaluating things.
This is much more
closely associated
with the first
Fundamental Theorem.
That is, we'll
take, today we were
talking about how integrals
are formulas for functions.
Or solutions to
differential equations.
We're going to go back
and talk about integrals
as being the answer to
a question as opposed
to what we've done now.
So in other words,
and the first example,
or most of the examples
for now, are going
to be taken from geometry.
Later on we'll get
to probability.
And the first topic is
just areas between curves.
Here's the idea.
If you have a couple of curves
that look like this and maybe
like this, and you want
to start at a place a
and you want to
end at a place b,
then you can chop it up the same
way we did with Riemann sums.
And take a chunk
that looks like this.
And I'm going to write the
thickness of that chunk.
Well, let's give
these things names.
Let's say the top curve is f(x),
and the bottom curve is g(x).
And then this thickness
is going to be dx.
That's the thickness.
And what is the height?
Well, the height
is the difference
between the top value
and the bottom value.
So here we have
(f(x) - g(x)) dx.
This is, if you like, base
times-- Whoops, backwards.
This is height, and this is
the base of the rectangle.
And these are
approximately correct.
But of course, only in limit
when this is an infinitesimal,
is it exactly right.
In order to get the whole
area, I have add these guys up.
So I'm going to
integrate from a to b.
That's summing them,
that's adding them up.
And that's going to be my area.
So that's the story here.
Now, let me just say
two things about this.
First of all, on a very
abstract level before we get
started with details of
more complicated problems.
The first one is
that every problem
that I'm going to be
talking about from now
on for several days, involves
the following collection
of-- the following goals.
I want to identify
something to integrate.
That's called an integrand.
And I want to identify what
are known as the limits.
The whole game is
simply to figure out
what a, b, and this
quantity is here.
Whatever it is.
And the minute we have that,
we can calculate the integral
if we like.
We have numerical
procedures or maybe we
have analytic
procedures, but anyway we
can get at the integral.
The goal here is to set them up.
And in order to set them up, you
must know these three things.
The lower limit,
the upper limit,
and what we're integrating.
If you leave one of these out,
it's like the following thing.
I ask you what the
area of this region is.
If I left out this end,
how could I possibly know?
I don't even know where it
starts, so how can I figure out
what this area is if
I haven't identified
what the left side is.
I can't leave out the bottom.
It's sitting here,
in this formula.
Because I need to
know where it is.
And I need to know the top
and I need to know this side.
Those are the four
sides of the figure.
If I don't incorporate
them into the information,
I'll never get anything out.
So I need to know everything.
And I need to know
exactly those things,
in order to have a
formula for the area.
Now, when this gets
carried out in practice,
as we will do now in
our first example,
it's more complicated
than it looks.
So here's our first example:
Find the area between x = y^2
and y = x - 2.
This is our first example.
Let me make sure that I chose
the example that I wanted to.
Yeah.
Now, there's a first step in
figuring these things out.
And this is that you
must draw a picture.
If you don't draw
a picture you'll
never figure out
what this area is,
because you'll never
figure out what's
what between these curves.
The first curve, y =
x^2, is a parabola.
But x is a function of y.
It's pointing this way.
So it's this parabola here.
That's y = x^2.
Whoops, x = y^2.
The second curve is a line,
a straight line of slope 1,
starting at x = 2, y = 0.
It goes through this place
here, which is 2 over
and has slope 1,
so it does this.
And this shape in
here is what we mean
by the area between the curves.
Now that we see what it
is, we have a better idea
of what our goal is.
If you haven't drawn
it, you have no hope.
Now, I'm going to describe two
ways of getting at this area
here.
And the first one is
motivated by the shape
that I just
described right here.
Namely, I'm going to use it
in a straightforward way.
I'm going to chop things up
into these vertical pieces
just as I did right there.
Now, here's the
difficulty with that.
The difficulty is that the
upper curve here has one formula
but the lower curve
shifts from being
a part of the parabola to being
a part of the straight line.
That means that there are
two different formulas
for the lower function.
And the only way
to accommodate that
is to separate this
up into two halves.
Separate it out into two halves.
I'm going to have to
divide it right here.
So we must break
it into two pieces
and find the integral of
one half and the other half.
Question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So, you're
one step ahead of me.
We'll also have to be
sure to distinguish
between the top branch and the
bottom branch of the parabola,
which we're about to do.
Now, in order to
distinguish what's going on
I actually have to
use multi colors here.
And so we will do that.
First there's the top
part, which is orange.
That's the top part.
I'll call it top.
And then there's the bottom
part, which has two halves.
They are pink, and I
guess this is blue.
All right, so now let's
see what's happening.
The most important two points
that I have to figure out
in order to get started here.
Well, really I'm going to have
to figure out three points,
I claim.
I'm going to have to figure
out where this point is.
Where this point is,
and where that point is.
If I know where these
three points are,
then I have a chance of knowing
where to start, where to end,
and so forth.
Another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Could you speak up?
PROFESSOR: The
question is, why do we
need to split up the area.
And I think in order to
answer that question further,
I'm going to have to go into
the details of the method,
and then you'll see
where it's necessary.
So the first step is that
I'm going to figure out
what these three points are.
This one is kind of easy;
it's the point (0, 0).
This point down here
and this point up here
are intersections
of the two curves.
I can identify them by
the following equation.
I need to see where
these curves intersect.
At what, well, if I plug in
x = y^2, I get y = y^2 - 2.
And then I can solve
this quadratic equation.
y^2 - y - 2 = 0.
So (y - 2) (y+1) = 0.
= 0.
And this is telling me
that y = 2 or y = -1.
So I've found y = -1.
That means this point down
here has second entry -1.
Its first entry, its x-value,
I can get from this formula
here or the other formula.
I have to square,
this, -1^2 = 1.
So that's the formula
for this point.
And the other point
has second entry 2.
And, again, with
his formula y = x^2,
I have to square y to
get x, so this is 4.
Now, I claim I have enough
data to get started.
But maybe I'll identify
one more thing.
I need the top, the bottom
left, and the bottom right.
The top is the formula for
this branch of x = y^2,
which is in the
positive y region.
And that is y is equal
to square root of x.
The bottom curve,
part of the parabola,
so this is the bottom left, is
y equals minus square root x.
That's the other branch
of the square root.
And this is exactly what
you were asking before.
And this is, we have to
distinguish between these two.
And the point is, these
formulas really are different.
They're not the same.
Now, the last bit is the
bottom right chunk here,
which is this pink part.
Bottom right.
And that one is the
formula for the line.
And that's y = x - 2.
Now I'm ready to find the area.
It's going to be in two chunks.
This is the left part,
plus the right part.
And the left part, and I want
to set it up as an integral,
I want there to be a dx and here
I want to set up an integral
and I want it to be dx.
I need to figure out
what the range of x is.
So, first I'm going
to-- well, let's
leave ourselves a little
more room than that.
Just to be safe.
OK, here's the right.
So here we have our dx.
Now, I need to figure out the
starting place and the ending
place.
So the starting place
is the leftmost place.
The leftmost place is over here.
And x = 0 there.
So we're going to travel
from this vertical line
to the green line.
Over here.
And that's from 0 to 1.
And the difference between the
orange curve and the blue curve
is what I call top and
bottom left, over there.
So that is square root of x
minus minus square root of x.
Again, this is what I call
top, and this was bottom.
But only the left.
I claim that's giving me
the left half of this,
the left section
of this diagram.
Now I'm going to do the
right section of the diagram.
I start at 1.
The lower limit is 1.
And I go all the way
to this point here.
Which is the last bit.
And that's going to be x = 4.
The upper limit here is 4.
And now I have to take the
difference between the top
and the bottom again.
The top is square root
of x all over again.
But the bottom has changed.
The bottom is now
the quantity x - 2.
Please don't forget
your parenthesis.
There's going to be minus
signs and cancellations.
Now, this is almost
the end of the problem.
The rest of it is routine.
We would just have to
evaluate these integrals.
And, fortunately, I'm
going to spare you that.
We're not going to
bother to do it.
That's the easy part.
We're not going to do it.
But I'm going to show you that
there's a much quicker way
with this integral.
And with this area calculation.
Right now.
The quicker way is what you see
when you see how long this is.
And you see that
there's another device
that you can use that looks
similar in principle to this,
but reverses the
roles of x and y.
And the other device, which I'll
draw over here, schematically.
No, maybe I'll draw it
on this blackboard here.
So, Method 2, if you
like, this was Method 1,
and we should call
it the hard way.
Method 2, which is
better in this case,
is to use horizontal slices.
Let me draw the picture,
at least schematically.
Here's our picture
that we had before.
And now instead of
slicing it vertically,
I'm going to slice
it horizontally.
Like this.
Now, the dimensions
have different names.
But the principle is similar.
The width, we now call dy.
Because it's the change in y.
And this distance here, from
the left end to the right end,
we have to figure out what the
formulas for those things are.
So on the left, maybe I'll
draw them color coded again.
So here's a left.
And, whoops, orange
is right, I guess.
So here we go.
So we have the left -
which is this green -
is x = y^2 And the right,
which is orange, is y = x - 2.
And now in order
to use this, it's
going to turn out that
we want to write x
as-- we want to reverse roles.
So we want to write this
as x is a function of y.
So we'll use it in this form.
And now I want to set
up the integral for you.
This time, the area is equal to
an integral in the dy variable.
And its starting
place is down here.
And its ending
place is up there.
This is the lowest value of y,
and this is the top value of y.
And we've already
computed those things.
The lowest level of y is -1.
So this is y = -1.
And this top value is y = 2.
So this goes from -1 to 2.
And now the difference
is this distance here,
the distance between
the rightmost point
and the leftmost point.
Those are the two dimensions.
So again, it's a rectangle
but its horizontal is long
and its vertical is very short.
And what are they?
It's the difference between
the right and the left.
The right-hand is y + 2,
and the right-hand is y^2.
So this is the formula.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What
was the question?
Why is it right minus left?
That's very important.
And that's actually the point
that I was about to make.
Which is this.
That y + 2, which is the
right, is bigger than y^2,
which is the left.
So that means that y
+ 2 - y^2 is positive.
If you do it backwards, you'll
always get a negative number
and you'll always
get the wrong answer.
So this is the right-hand
end minus the left-hand end
gives you a positive number.
And it's not obvious,
actually, where you are.
There's another
double-check, by the way.
When you look at this quantity,
you see that the ends pinch.
And that's exactly
the crossover points.
That is, when y =
-1, y + 2 - y^2 = 0.
And when y = 2, y + 2 - y^2 = 0.
And that's not an
accident, that's
exactly the geometry of the
shape that we picked out there.
So this is the technique.
Now, this is a much
more routine integral.
I'm not going to carry it out,
I'll just do one last step.
Which is that this is
y^2 / 2 + 2y - y^3 / 3,
evaluated at -1 and 2.
Which, if you work
it out, is 9/2.
So we're done for today.
And tomorrow we'll do
more volumes, more things,
including three dimensions.